ich weiß nicht wie es Ihnen geht aber
eigentlich hat man gar keine Lust mehr
aufs ewige ampelwäsche oder aber sie
zwingen einen ja förmlich schon wieder
Kanzler Machtworte diesmal zum Thema
Migration wie lange soll dieser
lächerliche Dauerstreit der noch
weitergehen geht in Therapie mein Gott
zumal ist ja wenn Sie darauf achten
immer nach demselben Muster läuft einer
fordert was wer anders sagt mit uns auf
keinen Fall und am Ende gewinnt die FDP
ja jedesmal jedes Mal ja wie so ein
Theaterstück was immer neu aufgeführt
wird die Liberalen nennen die Grünen
also ihren eigenen Koalitionspartner ein
Sicherheitsrisiko
wer soll diese Regierung noch ernst
nehmen die Tagesschau jedenfalls nicht
Bundeskanzler Scholz trifft sich heute
im Kanzler mit Vertreter der deutschen
Chemieindustrie um über die Zukunft der
Branche zu beraten
[Gelächter]
ist Cannabis eigentlich schon legal
ich hoffe ohne Drogen ist das alles
längst nicht mehr zu ertragen ich sage
nur Klimaschutz findet euch damit ab
Kinder Klimaschutz hat Pause wir kümmern
uns jetzt nur noch um wichtige
Erwachsenen Themen wie Wirtschaftskrise
oder Zahnersatz für Flüchtlinge solche
Klima machen wir später wenn man Zeit
ist ist ja so meldung vom Montag der
Gebäude Energieeffizienz Standard eher
40 wer kennt die nicht wird ausgesetzt
von der Ampel klar um der Bauindustrie
zu helfen logisch aber wenn man das von
heute auf morgen so einfach streichen
kann warum haben sie es dann vorher
überhaupt in den ampelvertrag
reingeschrieben gibt's überhaupt noch
sowas wie ein schlüssiges Konzept beim
Klimaschutz ich frage mal Frau Daubner
ja das dachte ich mir ja Deutschland
muss seinen CO2-Ausstoß in den nächsten
sieben Jahren halbieren ja das habe ich
neulich gelesen in der Energiewende die
stand das alles drin
und trotzdem verschieben wir die Gebäude
Energieeffizienz und habecks
heizhemmerchen gilt auch nur noch in
Neubauten wenn sie in Neubaugebieten
stehen er ist halt nicht drin in der
jetzigen Stimmung wie man sich selbst
eingebrockt hat mit schlecht gemacht und
wirklich unterirdisch kommunizierten
Gesetzen so läuft das eben in der
Realpolitik ne manchmal musst du nicht
am Ende mit der zweitbesten Lösung
zufrieden geben oder poetischer
formuliert wenn wir 95% sicher sind dass
es ganz gut ist dann sollten wir es
machen wenn 5% schief gehen dafür geht
aber alles 10 Jahre schneller als das
besser als wenn alles 100% oder 120%
richtig ist dafür alles zehn Jahre
länger dauert das glaube ich ist die
richtige Haltung also danke dass wir die
Jacken ausziehen durften wir wissen ja
was wir wollen also machen wir uns mal
auf den Weg und vielleicht lernen wir
das Laufen beim Gehen aber nicht beim
warten bis der Weg quasi komplett
geebnet ist das wird sowieso einen
rumflieger Weg ein Kopfsteinpflaster Weg
werden
was
Kopfsteinpflaster ey Leute ich habe gar
nichts verstanden aber ich werde es war
wieder ehrlich und irgendwie tief
Deutschland wird seine Klimaziele nicht
erreichen sagt habe sagt sinngemäß auch
der Expertenrat der Bundesregierung tja
hätten wir mal genauer hingeguckt bei
diesem Plakat hier wissen Sie noch
Kanzler für Klimaschutz leider stand im
Kleingedruckten aber nur wenn die
Wirtschaft gerade brummt nebenan kein
Krieg ist und nur ein Schaltjahr
mit dem neuen Klimaschutzgesetz der
Ampel letzten Freitag erstmal zur
Bundestag endet außerdem die lästige
Verantwortung der Minister für die
Klimabilanz ihrer Sektoren heißt vor
allem Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing
kann endlich mal durchschnaufen hoch
verdient finde ich oder ja ja er und
bauministerin David müssen kein
Sofortprogramm mehr nachlegen weil ihre
miese CO2 Bilanz ab jetzt mit den
anderen Ressorts verrechnet wird
verstehen sie das ist im Prinzip ja so
eine Art Montessori inklusionskabinett
ne wo wo gar keine Noten mehr vergeben
werden und nur noch die Performance der
ganzen Klasse zählt warum machen wir das
nicht überall so
mein Gott ja okay ich bin Rotze voll
aber du du musst es so sehen die ganzen
anderen Autofahrer die Feier nicht da
und das gleicht insgesamt alles wieder
aus verstehst du stimmt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich kann Ihnen sagen
wir leben insgesamt in seltsamen Zeiten
wettermoderatoren werden inzwischen
bedroht weil sie es wagen den
Klimawandel auch nur zu erwähnen
gleichzeitig juckt es aber keinen dass
die großen Öl und Gaskonzerne letztes
Jahr unfassbare 4 Billionen Dollar
Gewinn gemacht haben auch dann
staatlicher Subventionen auf
Rekordniveau für die fossile Industrie
mitten im Klimawandel keine so können
wir nicht weitermachen immerhin die
Engländer reagieren jetzt nur halt
anders als man denkt
großbritannien will dagegen seine
Klimapolitik
lockernde
britischen Familien zu hohe Kosten auf
wow ein mutiger move Freunde die Briten
Bremsen beim Klimaschutz und das als
Inselbewohner ja
nach dem brexit kommt also der klimaexit
der clexit im Grunde
das Verbrenner aus hat Premierminister
sunek zum Beispiel um 5 Jahre nach
hinten geschoben also das Herzstück von
Boris Johnson Klimapolitik verstehen sie
wie krank das ist wenn Boris Johnson
plötzlich die Stimme der Vernunft ist
der Klimaschutz kommt aus der Mode und
zwar weltweit umso wichtiger das Volker
Wissing jetzt mal konkret was macht fürs
Klimaschutz Image mit staatlicher
förderkohle für die Menschen die es
wirklich nötig haben richtig
Eigenheimbesitzer mit Elektroauto ja ja
ja Fakt wer außerdem eine Ladestation
eine Photovoltaikanlage und einen
solarstromspeicher hat kriegt vom Staat
on top bis zu 10.200 Euro geschenkt
getreu dem alten ftp-motto wenn ein
bisschen Arm geben wird es ja eh nur
versoffen
ja deshalb Geschenke für Leute die keine
brauchen für reiche Menschen warte mal
bin ich denn bescheuert ich stell sofort
meinen Antrag gestern erst ist ja das
neue solarstromförderprogramm gestartet
und schon heißt es Stopp zu groß der
Ansturm und 33.000 Anträge wurden laut
staatlicher Förderbank Kaffee schon
bewillig damit sein die 300 Millionen
Euro Haushaltsmittel für dieses Jahr
bereits ausgeschöpft
scheiße
die anderen wieder schneller als ich was
sollte denn bitte der Fördertopf die
selber Ampel schafft es nicht den
Bürgern ab Januar das versprochene Klima
Geld auszuzahlen wegen fehlender IBAN
oder ich habe keine Ahnung es ist nicht
zu fassen was die für Prioritäten setzen
und vor allem wie die Haushalten klarer
Fall für till Reiners
ist der heute-show Schuldenberater
so Olaf erstens sieht es hier aus wie
Sau und zweitens müssen wir dringend
über deine Finanzen reden vielen Kunden
sage ich wer kein Geld für Schulheft hat
soll erstmal aufhören zu rauchen dir
muss ich sagen Freundchen wer 100
Milliarden für die Bundeswehr verballert
muss auch noch irgendwo Klimagerät
rumliegen haben guck doch mal in den
Sofa Ritzen vielleicht Alter wusstest du
eigentlich dass du jedes Jahr 65
Milliarden für klimaschädliche
Subventionen ausgibst hast vergessen ne
erinnerungsbrücken wieder ne ja klar
kenne ich solche Leute angeblich kein
Geld für Butter aber sämtliche Streaming
Dienste im Abo hier gibt immer ein paar
Beispiele für Subvention die du sofort
streichen kannst Dienstwagen Privileg 3
Milliarden hauptsächlich deswegen fahren
immer noch so viele dicke Karren auf
unseren Straßen und ja ich weiß da
willst du dich nicht mit Christian
Lindner anlegen ne
Olaf du bist doch die falschen Freunde
geraten in ein Milieu das ist hoch
problematisch und das kämpft weiter für
den Verbrenner einfach weil
warum eigentlich
den den das Geräusch das Motorgeräusch
des Boxermotors Liebe weil ich gerne
forciert durch den Verkehr geleite
forciert gleiten auf Deutsch wie ein
Assi an allen vorbeiheizen oder nicht
warum wird Kerosin nicht besteuert warum
verschenkst du 4 Milliarden die auch
noch den Klimaschaden warum
Platz da wieder nur oder hier
diese Subvention über 8 Milliarden Euro
das sind pro Jahr drei
Kindergrundsicherung
Olaf ich habe echtes Gefühl du hast dich
aufgegeben so schade andere Kunden von
mir sind da inzwischen viel weiter
so ihr seht ich habe meinen Haushalt
hier im Griff
der Philipp gut der wohnt auch bei
seinen Eltern aber das ist ja nicht der
Punkt
Kompromissvorschlag könntest du
vielleicht wenigstens das mit dem Diesel
lassen selbstverständlich nicht weißt du
was mir reicht's ich finde jetzt
deine Mikrowelle und die Augenklappe
hier kriegst du beides erst wieder wenn
du dein Leben wieder im Griff hast
tschüss und lüfte mal mein Gott
[Musik]
nächste Woche wird in Bayern gewählt den
wichtigsten Bundesland der Welt
niedrige Arbeitslosenquote viel Hightech
Industrie es ist so sauber du kannst
praktisch überall vom Boden essen
Wahnsinn kurz gesagt man müsste sie
eigentlich gut finden die Bayern wenn
sie sich nicht selber so unerträglich
gut finden würden oder alter elender
Angeberei da unten ehrlich ich habe
nichts gegen Lokal Patriotismus gar
nicht wir Bielefelder haben auch viel
auf dass wir stolz sein können ne z.B
sind doch gar nicht der Punkt
mich nervt einfach dass alle bayerischen
waldsports hauptsächlich eine messen
haben ist es nicht unglaublich schön
hier Bayern ist ein schönes Land unser
wunderschönes Bayern herrlich die Sonne
geht auch das Wetter ist schön das ist
unser schönes Bayern für unser schönes
Bayern das ist schön das ist wunderschön
ja ist angekommen ihr schön wir scheiße
wie kann man denn mit seiner Landschaft
angeben hat der Söder die letzte
Kontinentalverschiebung befohlen damit
er die Alpen kriegt wahrscheinlich ja
außerdem täuscht die Idylle die wir
gerade gesehen haben meine Damen und
Herren die Stimmung im Wahlkampf da
unten ist eher hässlich vor allem die
Grünen kriegen wohl die geballte
anti-ampel Aggression ab ja
das ist gar nicht lustig neulich gab es
in Neu-Ulm sogar ein Steinwurf auf der
Spitzen du Hartmann und Schulze sowas
kann man jetzt natürlich auf einzelne
irre schieben oder auf Dauer Hetze im
Bierzelt inklusive Comedy-Programm wo
sie ist der Unterschied zwischen einem
normalen Waldarbeiter und einem grünen
Waldarbeiter wenn er Borkenkäfer Bäume
schält
der normale Walter schält den Baum und
das Ungeziefer zu bekämpfen und der
Grünewald ist auch Nahrungssuche
und und was ist der Unterschied zwischen
Hubert einwanger und einem normalen
Mistkäfer wenn der Mistkäfer Scheiße
baut wollte sie zusammen und schiebt sie
nicht auf seinem Bruder
[Applaus]
unglaublich
pupsiwanger der King of beard lässt als
sprechender Stammtisch sogar Markus
Söder alt aussehen damit will er Zitat
Aiwanger der AFD das Futter entziehen
also der bayerischen Alternative für
Deutschland mit ihrer Spitzenkandidatin
Katrin Ebner Steiner das Eiserne Kreuz
ah nee nein sorry nur ebener Steiner und
wenn die ihre Fans richtig heiß machen
will dann klingt das so
aber nicht so ein langweiliger seelenlos
so in der Elektromotor sondern ein
wütender schnaubender acht Zylinder
Drehmoment
[Musik]
ich will auch brutal in meinen Sessel
gedrückt werden
da ging jetzt ein bisschen schnell mit
den technischen Details das können Sie
aber alles nachlesen in der Automotoren
sind wir ehrlich ein richtiger Wahl
Krimi wird das wahrscheinlich nicht
nächste Woche Söder hat sich sehr früh
ausschließlich an Hubert Aiwanger
gekettet ja sehr früh also
gekettet an dem Buch stetig letzten
Menschen von dem man abhängig sein will
ja es ging aber nicht anders war
alternativlos denn den Grünen fehlt
Zitat Söder das Bayern gehen
ist ein Begriff ne ja ist was ganz
exklusives das Bayern gehen kriegst du
eigentlich nur wenn deine Vorfahren über
Generationen im selben Dorf ihre Cousine
gehabt haben
ja Bayern gehen außerdem sieht Söder
sich ja als Stachel im Fleisch der Ampel
und die Ampel ist bekanntlich Schuld an
allem sogar an seinen Umfragen so
richtig verfängt der Frust an der Ampel
nicht bei ihnen woran liegt das denn ja
das liegt natürlich ganz die Ampel so
schwierig so schlechter weidet dass
viele Menschen sich fast schon
verabschieden aus der Demokratie wir
spüren es richtig ja der spürt gar
nichts mehr es ist der Wahnsinn
seine Umfragen Politbarometer von heute
meine Damen und Herren nur 36 % für
Söder und Armin Laschet so zu Hause
[Musik]
aber komm fakt ist keiner zahlt so viel
ein beim Länderfinanzausgleich wie
Bayern man könnte auch sagen sie sind
fast überall top außer bei der
Energiewende Strom ist so ein Thema da
können wir anderen armen Länder den
Bayern auch mal was zurückgeben und
Christian Ehring moderiert genau jetzt
direkt nebenan die passende
charity-sendung ich gehe mal kurz rüber
[Applaus]
hallo
hallo Olli
grüß Gott Mensch Christian ich finde das
so toll dass du dich um dieses wichtige
Anliegen kümmerst absolut Oliver ich bin
auch gerührt von mir selber herzlichen
willkommen zur großen ZDF
Wohltätigkeitsgala
pferdestrohm bezahlbare Energie für alle
selbst für Bayern dazu muss man wissen
der Freistaat produziert zu wenig
Windenergie auch die Stromtrassen
Richtung Süden sind immer noch nicht
fertig und wer ist schuld na
die Grünen
nein also auch natürlich die Grünen sind
immer irgendwie Schuld aber im konkreten
Fall war es wohl auch die sorry Doofheit
der letzten csu-regierungen gerade
Seehofer hat aus Angst vor
Bürgerinitiativen jahrelang Windräder
und Trassen ausgebremst jetzt werden sie
auf Wunsch der Bayern verbunden was aber
alles noch langsamer und teurer macht ja
gut das war vielleicht blöd von den
beiden Christian aber seit wann wird man
bei uns für Blödheit bestraft Leben
liebe Zuschauer schauen Sie in diese
Augen
und sagen sie mir dass sie die Markus
keinen bezahlbaren Strom können
ich kann sie ich auch wobei im Moment
muss man wissen zahlen ja die Länder im
Norden also die rechtzeitig Windräder
und Leitungen gebaut haben zur Strafe
mehr für ihren Strom weil die
Anschlusskosten als Netzentgelt auf
jeden Haushalt umgelegt werden und da
oben halt weniger Menschenleben ist auch
irgendwie unfair bitte wieso unfair
sollen jetzt die Bayern ausbaden dass
die Friesen zu faul sind zum knattern
oder was einfach mal helfen welke wo
bleibt denn die Hilfsbereitschaft wissen
Sie eigentlich was die EU den Armen
Bayern antun will die fordern mehr
Wettbewerb Deutschland soll sich
aufteilen in mehrere stromärkte Kuckuck
dann wird's aber im Norden billiger und
im Süden teurer das kann doch wirklich
keiner wollen Moment ich dachte die CSU
wäre für den freien Markt Schnauze
geteilte stromärkte ja zu dem
Schwachsinn hat Markus Söder gerade erst
alles Nötige gesagt
und es reicht die ständige
Benachteiligung
Bayerns reicht diese ständige
sie müssen uns nicht fördern okay sie
müssen uns nicht pimpern okay
ich will die gar nicht pimpern natürlich
wollen sie die pimpern geben Sie doch zu
jeder will die pimpern der Söder hat
völlig Recht wenn er sagt wer
strompreiszonen das Wort redet legt die
Axt an den Industriestandort Deutschland
ja wenn er Deutschland sagt weiter
Bayern seine Industrie würde dann
nämlich nach Norden abwandern weil da
der Strom billiger wäre liebe Zuschauer
ignorieren sie das herzlose Schwein
neben mir einfach rufen Sie jetzt an und
spenden sie Strom für Bayern jede
Kilowattstunde jedes Milliampere hilft
und während sie zum Hörer greifen zeig
ich Ihnen die neueste erneuerbare
Energie made in Bavaria diese Halterung
nennt sich Platte Power Strom durch
Schulplan genial
[Musik]
Niedersachsen das auch ich nehme alles
zurück
hallo Leute Ich bin's der heute-schule
wenn ihr mehr heißen Scheiß und liegt
dann abonniert jetzt den Kanal
was zur Hölle ist ein Mähne Ersteller
[Musik]